it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week we're going to Victorian
era London where you're using advanced
future guns to take down half-breed
monsters Galahad is in an elite order of
knights of the round table that keeps
the peace between normies and what
appear to be aggressive chimeras but the
humans are losing after they discover
black water that increases their
lifespan and allows them to heal like
Wolverine they get some electric weapons
and start kicking butt but as humans
typically do they start fighting with
each other because the lower class is
starting to rebel against the rich in
the social order those poor people just
don't know when to stay down take on the
filthy muggles and the disgustingly less
fortunate on the 20th but if that's a
little too real for your tender psyche
and you prefer to play games to escape
your war filled life consider the
colorful and happy-go-lucky world of
Kirby which is making its way to North
America this week sadly Kirby's got a
curse and it's a rainbow curse Oh No
some of the color has been stolen and
it's up to Kirby to float roll and
dances way to victory in this adorable
claymation extravaganza party it up with
waddle dees on the 20th and back to
reality where people are poor and
there's war in Europe going on Attila
the Hun is not missing around and people
must come together to take him down
provinces are groupings of up to four
regions and each region is yours for the
taking but you'll have to deal with
keeping your army in line against
mounting losses disloyal generals and
fragmented food supplies it's tough to
be king mount your horse on the 17th
also this week dead or alive 5 last
round makes an appearance focusing on
some new characters the back from the
dead right oh and the shockingly unique
cutesy schoolgirl Hanukkah but she has
the ability to gain other characters
fighting styles so she might actually be
a lot tougher than she appears her
interest includes school hanging with
her loving grandmother and breaking
necks with her bare hands find out if
her fighting technique is as deep as her
character design on the seven
team for further details visit gamespot
com release dates are based on retailer
listings and are always subject to
change see you next week